votre attention s'il vous plaît c'est
important j'ai quelque chose à vous
montrer mais quand je vais vous montrer
ce que je vais vous montrer vous ne
paniquez
pas je vous
explique qu'est-ce que j'aime ça quand
j'entends vive le vent les voisins se
disputent le titre très convoité de la
maison la mieux décoré du quartier moi
je dis que c'est la maison à
battre quel est votre V de
Noël je veux juste gagner ce
[Musique]
concours je prends
celuici s'il vous plaît ne faites pas
attention petit caractère c'est comme si
vous renonciz à votre vie joyeux Noël
joyux Nol il le sera
[Musique]
forcément il se passe un truc bonjour
monsieur est-ce que tu es réel onétait
tous jusqu'à ce qu'on tombe dans le
piège tordu de cette
Elf tu as fait un V tu es coincé
maintenant j'ai pas signé pour ça et
bien signé pour ça faut toujours l ce
qui écrit en touttit me les clos sont
sans
pitiées Adu à votre
père pourquoi vous êtes SAP comme des
[Musique]
prince on la laissera pas transform
votre père En l'un de ses jouets à p000
bizarre sans vouloir vous vexer il y a
pas de mal bah un peu
si on est les
carveurs on doit attraper un
Elf ça pique quand on se frotte au
carveur on devrait se séparer se séparer
qu'est-ce que tu racontes non mais tu as
jamais vu un film d'horreur dès qu'un
groupe se sépare il y a un mort direct
tu as déjà été mort non et ben c'est pas
marrant je confirme même si j'ai jamais
étaé mort mais votre mère est au courant
tu m'avais caché ta mort allons chercher
ses
[Musique]
anneau est-ce que c'est lui oh mon dieu
c'est le père Noirel j'étais sûr que
c'était un
frère